- Hello and a warm, warm
welcome to our session
on modernizing Mercedes-Benz's
Global Ordering system
with Rocket on AWS and also using GenAI.
My name is Manuel Breitfield.
I'm heading the delivery
for Mercedes-Benz Germany
at Capgemini, and I'm very, very excited
to be standing here today with Christian.
- Thanks, Manuel, and a warm
welcome also from my side.
I'm Christian Klemme
from Mercedes-Benz IT,
based in Stuttgart, Germany,
and happy to be here with Manuel
to make you familiar with our big project,
which we call "Go to Cloud"
because it's about the application
Global Ordering, in short, GO.
Together with Capgemini and more partners,
we move to the cloud from the mainframe.
I will actually start
by making you familiar
a little bit with the
dimensions of this application.
On the left-hand side of
this slide, you can see
the process that is supported
by this application.
It's, if you want, the lifeline
of our sales operations
at Mercedes-Benz, and
we always visualize this
by using the letter Y
because it's the processes
that are behind.
If you look from the right-hand side,
there is all master data creation.
So, this is how we set up more or less
our product portfolio
inside Global Ordering,
and this is where the orders come in
based on that master data.
From the left-hand side,
you can see what we call
Volume Planning or sales planning.
This is where we more or less determine
how many cars we want
to sell in which market,
which type of cars we want
to sell in which period.
Then all this data comes
together in Global Ordering,
and based on this, we do the ordering
and we also serve
production with the orders.
So, you can imagine, and that is stated
on the bottom of this
picture, each and every car
that we sell, that we produce,
goes through the system landscape.
This is why I actually said this is where
the heartbeat of the company goes.
To give you some numbers,
only selected ones,
I'm not going to read you
through the entire slide,
we talk about an application
that has more than
20,000 interfaces in all
parts of our company.
If you look at the size of the application
in terms of lines of code, we talk about
5 million lines of code in Java and COBOL
and more or less the same
size in the other languages.
We have, yeah, a huge workload,
at least for our dimensions.
So, roundabout 50% of
the mainframe workload
is with Global Ordering.
Technically spoken, we
support more than 800 queues,
we support more than 5.1
billion messages per year,
and we have 450 batches running
on the mainframe application.
By this, we support more than
8,000 users in 150 countries.
So, it's quite impressive.
For us, it's super
important, and this is why
we decided not to refactor the application
but to go in more steps to
start with the re-platforming,
and this is what we want to present today.
So, how did we tackle this
program or this project
of re-platforming this
important application
for Mercedes-Benz?
You can see the steps right here.
We started already more
than two years ago.
Once having the idea, then
going through the rapid
assessment together with the
provider Rocket Software,
who provides this assessment
as a standard service
for all applications, for
all workloads that are
supposed to move from the
mainframe to the cloud.
Having this assessment done,
we then looked at the results
and initiated the mitigating measures
for the trouble or for
the issues that we found.
Of course, we had to
calculate the business case,
which at the beginning
already showed us significant
cost savings compared
to what we have as cost
on the mainframe today.
This is more or less also
how we initiated the entire
mainframe exit program that is
running now at Mercedes-Benz.
So, the entire company is
about to leave this platform
in the next couple of years.
How did we tackle it
from a team perspective?
In the end, we decided for Capgemini
to be our general contractor.
So, as you can imagine
and as we will show later,
there's a whole team and
a whole number of partners
that are acting together
here to make this happen.
But we chose for Capgemini
to be our general contractor
who manages for us the
relationship between
the other partners, namely AWS of course
is the provider of the cloud platform,
but also Rocket as
being the one serving us
with what they call the Enterprise Server,
so the emulation for mainframe
workloads on the cloud.
And of course, we as the MMB customers,
we also are part of the game
together, IT and business,
which is also one of
the key success factors.
Then in 2025, we finally got
the go to start a project.
We have strong management
involvement, of course,
which is important top
management involvement.
We also applied GenAI in
first POC pilot setups,
but later then also for larger workloads,
and Manuel will be speaking about that
a little bit more in detail in a minute.
Also from our perspective, a clear factor
for success is that we go in stages.
We start with parts of the application.
In this case, we even start
with a stateless part,
with some stateless
services which are part
of the application, to make
sure that we can really
run this in parallel on the old platform
and the new platform to be sure
that the new implementation
on the cloud serves
to the same levels of service
as the old application.
For 2026, we have still a way to go.
We will then migrate the
full-size application,
have to cancel all our legacy contracts,
also make sure that the
business case really is
implemented and realized
and the savings really come,
and of course, set up the
future mode of operations
on the new platform with the new partners
and finally fully dismantle the mainframe,
which is super important
in terms of getting
really rid of the cost.
Another key success factor is what we call
the Global Ordering Facade.
What do we mean with the facade?
That's also based on a standard product
that we buy from MuleSoft.
It's a gateway which allows
you to direct the workload
that comes from our web clients to either
the cloud backend or
the mainframe backend,
which is of course a very handy feature
in terms of testing, but also allows you
a very quick way back in terms of trouble.
And of course, that's
the most important part,
prevents all your consumers
from doing huge changes
when interacting with you.
They simply have to call another URL
but will not be impacted by
what we do in the background
when migrating the application.
So, this is how we believe we can migrate
this huge application
with the highest speed
at the lowest risk, also fully integrated
in the existing Mercedes-Benz landscape,
being then ready for the future
from a technology
perspective, but still having
all options open in terms of modernizing
the application towards a more modern
and cloud-native structure.
One more thing that is
important in our project
is the platform that we move to.
It's not an AWS native landing
zone that we are going at.
We have mentioned Rocket
as one of the software
providers many times now.
Rocket Software and their product,
the Enterprise Server, is more or less
the landing zone that we need to emulate
the mainframe on the cloud.
This landing zone is fully managed by AWS,
so not something that we have to manage
from Mercedes-Benz or Germany side,
but we just buy this
as a service from AWS.
But more than that, Rocket
is only the mainframe part.
We also have a Java stack on the cloud.
We have some services
for batch processing,
but also of course for database services.
Messaging is an important part.
Then all the things that
you need on top, of course,
like monitoring, financials, and so on.
The storage part is all
combined in this landing zone,
or this platform which we
call the Helios platform.
It's a Mercedes-Benz internal
product that combines
some of IAM services that
we need on top, of course,
with the standard services that you find
on that landscape that I have just shown.
So, that's about all, but
most important not to mention,
last but not least, is the partnership
that we have set up to make
this program successful.
Starting of course with us as the customer
who are the ones who want
to realize this project,
but moreover than the
general contract that we have
is Capgemini supported
by the two main partners:
AWS as the cloud platform
provider and Rocket
as being the inventor of
the Enterprise Server,
the emulation of the
mainframe in the cloud.
With this, I'm happy
to hand over to Manuel,
who will make you familiar a little bit
with the GenAI part of the story,
which is of course the most exciting one.
So, let's go ahead, Manuel.
- Thank you, Chris. Thank you, Christian.
Before we come to the GenAI topic,
maybe let me walk you
backwards a little bit.
If you're familiar with the
topic of legacy modernization,
you might know those phases.
So, typically when we go
into mainframe modernization,
we look into four phases,
and with those four phases,
we try to find the best solution
for that specific problem.
So, typically you want to
start with the assess phase
where you look into the whole landscape.
Now with Mercedes-Benz
for Global Ordering,
we've also done that, but
also Capgemini is doing that
application for over 25 years.
So, we kind of knew
already what's at stake.
We kind of knew the application,
we kind of knew how it's
integrated into the landscape.
Christian said it's about
huge, huge interfaces
that we have to deal with.
So we knew that if we don't know it,
we help ourselves with tools.
CAP360 is one of them.
BREAD is another one that is also using AI
to determine how the
application structure looks like
and how interfaces look like.
As soon as this is clear
and as soon also the client is clear
on what the strategy is,
Christian mentioned for Global Ordering
we've chosen the
re-platforming or rehosting,
some call it re-platform,
some call it re-hosting,
so basically kind of an emulation
on the mainframe with Rocket.
As soon as you have that, you decide,
okay, this is our strategy.
You see the "6 Rs", some have five,
some have seven, here it's six.
Basically, what is your
migration strategy?
For Global Ordering,
we've chosen to go with a
re-platforming approach.
We wanted to keep the application
as untouched as possible
and also be sure that, kind
of the interfaces we have,
we have a good way to deal with that.
But also, and this is where I'm coming in
with regards to AI, at the very beginning,
we already knew there might be some cases
where we want to go refactor
because at the same time Mercedes-Benz
is doing their Sales Operations,
is refactoring parts of that already.
So, it does make sense from
a business case perspective
to look into Global Ordering at once
but also see if there were some slices
that would make sense to refactor them.
So, that was the idea.
When we went into the
migrate and modernize part,
we actually identified the
parts where we felt like
those would be good
elements to refactor them.
GenAI is mentioned in the bottom,
I come to that shortly.
And obviously, not to
forget operate and optimize.
We are not at that stage yet,
but we are just starting to
have first services available
where we learn how to operate
and how to optimize them.
But definitely a big,
big part of the story.
If we look into the AI and
GenAI effects of those phases,
those are the elements
that we at Capgemini use.
So for the assessment, I've
mentioned that earlier,
we use a couple of tools
that help us identify
what is the inventory, how
does the code look like,
and also what is business cases,
what are business rules that are being
included in the application.
This is where we use BREAD, CAP360,
or also Gen Insights,
tools that just help us
to get a bit of an idea
on the application.
The other part is Agentic
AI refactoring, and I mean,
if you listened to some
of the sessions today
and probably also coming this week,
that's a big, big story.
It's also a big story here.
So with GenAI, which I will
come to later in the talk,
we have a multi-agent
setup based on agentic AI
that does transform legacy
code into the new world.
Obviously, we also use coding assistance.
So all developers, and
we've heard in the keynote
as well, like all developers,
happy to use some assistance while coding.
This is also true here.
And then when it comes to testing,
we also have tools that help us identify
was the test successful or is
there an error in the testing?
But as I said, I want to come to GenAI,
and this is what we have been implementing
basically this year
within Global Ordering,
and the headline states
kind of the key message:
We don't just use AI;
we want to combine it
with our expertise and our strength.
So on the left-hand side of the picture,
you see this is what our
team currently still does
and where I believe it's fully
essential that they do it.
So it's about having an
analysis of the application,
knowing what do I
actually want to refactor;
I need to know it.
Also providing documents:
what are the documents
that are helpful for the AI
to be able to transform the code, right?
It's not only the code, it's
also documentation that exists,
it's test cases that might exist.
So all the things that you have
that do help the AI to better transform,
that's helpful and you need to provide it,
and obviously, you need
to specify what to do.
Like in this case, it's we want to migrate
from COBOL to Java, so I need to tell,
I need to learn, I need to
train the AI how it's done.
To be able to do so in GenAI,
we call it "cookbooks."
I need to explain, I need to say like,
"Look, this is how you
would typically transform
that module into that part in Java"
to give the AI kind of a feeling
on what's right and what's wrong.
And GenAI then in turn has,
it's similar like a
software engineering team.
You have the agent being
the software engineer,
you have the agent being
the software reviewer,
you have the tester, you
have the DevOps engineer,
and actually, you really have
roles you assign to the AI.
"Look, you are the agent,
you are the engineer,"
and that agent does software engineering.
It doesn't do testing
because there's a different role for that.
So what they do, they
kind of build a software
engineering team that is
then orchestrated by a human.
This is kind of the basis,
and while it might look
like theory on paper,
it's actually already on production
and has been able to transform
quite a number of code for Mercedes-Benz.
Now, looking into that specific case,
so I called it, we within Go to Cloud,
within the application at Mercedes-Benz,
there is one service
called Pricing Service
consisting of 1.3 million lines of code,
1.3 million lines of COBOL code.
What you see on that slide,
I mean it's kind of
the rough architecture,
is running on the mainframe.
It is split between a Java part
which is running on IBM WebSphere
and a COBOL part which is on IBM CICS,
both parts accessing the same database
and Java calling COBOL as well.
This is what we have today,
and what we've decided is
we want to migrate the
COBOL part into Java
and have just one application after that.
So the outcome, you see
it on the right-hand side,
is Christian mentioned the GO Facade.
This is kind of the layer sitting on top.
This is where all calls go
in, this is where we can check
is it a successful test
case or is it unsuccessful.
This is where we can
also route certain calls.
So, should that call already
go on the new Java part
or should it stay on the mainframe?
This is kind of the tooling
that allows us to do testing
that allows us also to
control the go-live.
And also what Christian mentioned earlier,
it allows us to minimize changes
with all neighboring systems.
They should not do a lot of changes.
In fact, they only change the URL.
And then in yellow, you
see the new Java stack.
So everything which is on the two boxes
on the left-hand side,
we have the COBOL part,
we have the Java part,
everything is now moved
into Java with GenAI,
and there was still one problem.
Like, the COBOL part and the Java part,
they have been accessing
the same database,
and it's a Pricing Service,
but in fact, it's also part
of the whole Global Ordering system.
So the data in that specific case
is still existing on the mainframe.
So, what we've used is
Precisely as a tool.
Precisely is able to basically
sync data, lots of data,
basically in real-time.
So what we are doing is, to
be able to have that data
accessible on the new service,
we use Precisely to always
sync that data in real-time.
With that, we not only
have the new service
more in your new target language,
we have been able to
reduce mainframe costs
at the same time and have also been able
to actually increase the speed
for the neighboring systems.
So that's the core concept.
I've talked a bit on the story already,
but I just also want to
walk you through that again.
I feel like nowadays when
people talk about GenAI,
I think it's always better if
you show how it actually went.
It all started with a problem,
I think beginning of the year,
that that Pricing Service
that was on the mainframe
was not capable of executing as many calls
as Mercedes-Benz would
need for modernizing parts
of their new system.
So the problem was what to do?
Should we up the mainframe infrastructure
and try to just make it bigger
to be able to handle those calls,
or the other solution was try GenAI.
In fact, it was kind of trying GenAI,
not fully knowing if it would succeed.
So that was beginning of February,
but we decided, okay, let's try that,
knowing that the number of lines of code
with the 1.3 million is quite a challenge.
But in March, if we look back,
there was actually already
the first commit into
the GitHub repository,
and not too much later in May,
we had the first version
which was deployable.
So really in a very, very
short time, we were able
to transform the 1.3 million lines of code
into a Java application.
And just recently, because so
many people are asking now,
"How does that code look like?
Are you able to maintain it?",
just recently we've looked into the code,
and you're not able to distinguish
is that code written by a human
or is it the AI that has written that.
Also, to be frank, there are some parts,
and you see it in the
additional performance tuning,
there are some parts that
we did adjust manually.
So especially coming from
legacy, coming from the mainframe
where in this case database
access is just very, very quick
and everything is in memory, obviously,
that's not the case on AWS,
and it shouldn't be like that.
So there are parts that you need to tune
and that the AI in this stage
does not know that it should be tuned.
So what we did is we looked
into all the database accesses
and this is where we've
done some fine-tuning
to be able to max out the
speed that we needed to do.
Also, all the infrastructure setup,
mainframe now is running on AWS,
and the Precisely data
sync also fully functional,
then in September, and not long ago,
I think almost one month,
one and a half months back,
there was a big, big
go-live for Mercedes-Benz
of that whole system.
The Pricing Service is a part of that
and went live successfully.
Actually, is faster than before
with that GenAI use case.
Now, having that in mind and
also having that success story
checked, we are currently evaluating
together with Mercedes-Benz
what are other parts
where we feel like we will
find a similar success story,
where parts where we feel like, okay,
we don't want to just refactor,
we don't want to just rehost;
we want to refactor
and we want to use the benefits of GenAI.
So summing that story up,
it's 1.3 million lines of COBOL code.
It's also 500 megabytes
of database records
that are kept in sync in real-time.
So it's really, really a big achievement.
Now, one last thing that I want to come to
is the facade or integration
layer that we also call it.
Was now in production and
was really a key element
to be able to test the whole service
but also to be able to bring it live.
So while we did the QA
phase, the testing phase,
the UAT phase, we were always able
to use the integration layer
and route calls to mainframe,
but also route calls to Java,
and because Precisely was still
taking care of the database,
so it was really clear
like for both worlds
you should get the exact same result.
So this is what we did in testing.
We've monitored all calls
and we've actually looked
into the integration layer
and it was a simple check,
like the result that you
get from both systems
should be the same, right?
This reduced the testing effort enormously
because it was not only
able to check it manually,
we were also able to test with real data.
It was not like someone who needed
to sit and test certain systems.
We were able to use and capture real data
and just run it against the two systems
and then be able to go into
production with a good check.
It turned out well also in production.
As soon as we went live,
we were also able to
test both of the systems
and were able to compare
all of those results.
Moreover, it's not only a
functionality that we use
and that I think you
should use in the system
to compare results.
It's also something where you can monitor
what is your latency,
what is your throughput,
how is speed looking?
Are you achieving against SLAs or not?
Like all those NFRs
that you certainly have
in your applications.
You can also check that
if you have something
like an integration layer,
something like a facade.
And what is written on the
right in the outcome section:
Control cut-over, we've said that already,
like you can control the systems,
when should they change?
And then it's your decision to turn over;
is not their decision.
You can control it.
You have your automated quality assurance
because you are actually
doing all the tests
with the facade.
In this specific case,
obviously all of us very proud,
we actually didn't have
any incident on go-live
for such a big system which
again was migrated with AI.
And lastly on that screenshot, yeah,
the colors are visible here too.
You see what the result is:
yellow is the mainframe system
that was running before,
the Pricing Service on the
mainframe system in COBOL.
Green is the one in Java.
And you see it has been
running in parallel
for quite a while.
It's just a testing that I've said,
and then at a certain point in time,
we were able to just cut
it off as we've seen it.
The performance is just better
all the way, and even spikes,
you can handle it much
better on AWS obviously
than you would be able to handle it
on a mainframe system.
Yeah, and with that,
we are done with the
presentation for today.
We would be very happy to
answer a couple of questions
if you have them.
We stand right by and
happy you listened here,
and see you then, thank you very much.